what are what are we back with my man
here with some of the most exclusive in
high-end Japan whiskey on the face of
this earth 2 Chainz man charge
nice music George why are they so rare
whiskey take st. the age didn't earn
enough to keep up with the man this cost
ten thousand ten thousand dollars have
you tasted anything exclusive before
[Music]
oh yeah this one uses Japanese I just
called me Senora
and like the whiskey as rare as well
because they it takes 200 years for the
tree to be ready to be made into a cask
so that's chef jumping these japanese
japanese japanese japanese japanese
japanese oak something from japan made
in taiwan man Japanese whiskey would
come on with it man this kisses it
tastes like Japanese all you can taste
the Japanese oh I feel like I gained
this much more knowledge on the Japanese
culture as well as they are whiskey
[Music]
you can listen what you want the stars
fall down my see can be legs break me
then my seat layer that's all I'm a move
in a minute
I just you know said this is gonna be
over to our last set up so as soon as
you guys are good I'm just gonna yank
all this stuff
[Music]